- C'est le joyau des parcs
nationaux duun incontournable cé
au Patrimoine mondial
de l'UNESCO.eueueueueueueueueues
annuels, Banff attire à lui seul
le quart de toutes les visites
dans l'ensemble des parcs
Mais cette popularité a un prix.
MARIE-ÈVE MARCHAND,
- Mais de plus en plus,
voilà qananananannées,
on ne voyait jamais du monde sur
la pointe là-bas, puis d'autre
c'est en train de s'agrandir,
s'agrandir...
- La pression des touristes
sur les divers écosystèmes n'a
MaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaMaÈe
de la conservation et résidente
de Banff.
Concrètement, ça a quoi
comme impact, cette presysysysy?
- Ça a plusieurs différences.
Ça peut être une pression
au quotidien : les journées
sont d
il y a de plus en plus de monde
tôt le matin et tard.....
Ça veut dire que la faune a
pour se nourrir, circuler avecs.
Il y a plus de piétons,
donc il y a deseseseseseseseses.
Comme on peut voir ici,
il y a vraiment comme... il y a
une route principale, mais tout
quatre autres sentiers.
Donc il y a une multiplication
de l'empreinte vraiment,
de
- Parcs Canada est
bien conscient dèèèèème.
Une nouvelle approche
sur le stationnement et p p p pe
d'ici deux ans. Le tout fait
partie d'un nouveau plan pour
la prochaine décennie du parc.
secteur Lake Louise, Parcs Can.
- Aulelelelele nombre de voies
puis augmenter les places
de stationnements,açaçaçaçaçaça.
- Le surintendant du site de
Lake Louise doit nous amener
lui-même sur place; sinon,
la navette parce que
le stationnement déborde
dès l'aube.
L'e
devra forcément être modifiée,
explique François Masse :
non seulement certains espaces
de stationnement pourraient être
réduits, des sendededededededede
fermés pour donner un répit l l.
- D'un site à l'autre,
on a des types de visiteurs
de pressions différentes,
donc ce qu'on va f
c'est qu'on a, par site,
on va avoir des plans de gestioe
différents.
mais aussi le nom
mumumumumunicipalité de près
de 9000 résidents.
Transport en come e e e e e e ee
en été ou encore stationnement
incitatif; la ville de Banff
fait également tout ce qu'elle
des voitures.
Que ce soit Parcs Canada ou
la ville, tout le monde à Banff
doit s'attaquer à la réduction
de l'empreinte écologique du
tourisme, estime Corrie DiManno.
Protéititititite exceptionnel,
sans en restreindre l'accès :
tout le défi est là.
- Puis on le voit dans plusieu
autres sites du Patrimoine
mondial à travers la planète,
Banff n'est pas unique.
- Donner accès aux gens au parc,
c'est aussi préserver le parc
les générations futures.
- Parce que pour c
la carte postale des Rocheuses,
l'envers du décor doit changer.
Radio-Canada, Banff.